A woman who
was allegedly
held against her
will for nearly
a year is free this morning
after escaping from her alleged kidnaper
by fleeing to a New Jersey gas station.
Here's her escape.
It was caught on camera.
You see the woman
who's not been identified,
she's running, she's barefoot.
She's only in a T-shirt
in 42nd degree weather.
And you see the man
that was closely following her,
he tries to get in,
but she deadbolts the door
when he realizes he can't get inside.
He turns around and leaves.
And that's when the owner steps
in helping her
get to the back of the gas station
where they call police.
Now, her alleged abductor is 57 year
old James Perillo,
and he's now behind bars
on kidnaping and assault charges.
Authorities say
that he choked her
multiple times, that at one point
he took away her cell phone
and used her credit cards
and isolated her from her family.
They also say he goes by different names
and may have actually done this before
in other states.
CNN has reached out to an attorney
listed for Perillo,
but we've yet to hear a response.
Joining us
this morning
is one of the heroes of this story.
The owner of that gas station,
Bobby Madsen,
who helped
keep the woman safe until police arrived.
Bobby, good morning.
We're so grateful
that you're sharing the story with us.
Walk us through what that day was like.
When did you first see her
and realize that something was wrong?
Hi.
Good morning.
Yeah, it was just a regular day
at the gas station.
I was in the backroom
doing paperwork
and my employee was in the front
just having a little break.
And all of a sudden
we hear this screaming and yelling.
And I look up on the camera,
there's somebody
running on the side of the building.
Then there at the front,
and I could see the woman
and the men right behind her.
Excuse me.
And so my employee gave me
and her come into the store,
and they locked the door.
By the time I get out to the office,
I see the guys trying to open the door.
But we kind of look at each other
and he is gone and she is frantic.
She is shaken.
She was really, really scared.
You could tell
I couldn't grasp in the first 10 seconds
what was going on.
I just knew that this woman needed help.
My employer knew this woman needed help.
Help her. I'll get her in.
And my employee told me
that she was screaming on the way here
that I've been kidnaped.
This man has kept me for too long.
And that's exactly
what she repeated to me
when she got in the office.
So we just got her to sit down
and give her a safe place and told her
we're calling the police.
Do not worry. Nobody's coming in here.
While Bobby,
I'm sure she's
grateful to you and your employee
You said you made contact
or eye contact with this guy.
What did you see on his face?
Did did anything stand out to you?
I'm just.
You know what?
It was almost
any moment of.
Yes, him being mad.
And I guess also realizing,
oh, like I'm in trouble.
So when she's
screaming and yelling,
what are you trying to say to her?
What was the approach like
it was just that
it was just an normal human approach.
Like, you know what?
You're going to be okay.
There's nobody coming in her
and nobody coming in the place anymore.
You're in the office.
I took her right to the office
so she can sit in the office
so she can't see outside,
even if he comes back
so she doesn't get any more worried. And
she she was desperately in need of help.
And, like I said,
couldn't really understand
for the first few seconds
what was going on.
But you could see
she had some marks on her neck.
So we know
she was not in the right place.
She needs help.
Just get her in the back.
And she sat down and we called the police
and just
just although he is not getting in here
because she kept looking around,
looking at the walls, like,
is he going to break in the walls,
get in here.
And I constantly kept
talking to her, actually
gave me my employee
got on the phone with the police,
and I just kept telling her, like,
do not worry, he is not coming in here.
Nobody's coming and half right now.
So, yeah,
that's all we could do for her
at that moment. Calm her down.
Right.
Understandably, somebody
in that situation
would be scared that way, even paranoid.
Have you gotten a chance to talk to her
since that encounter?
She did reach out to me,
but just through a phone call,
and she just wanted to thank
and I told her, like, you know,
I don't thank us
because we were simply there.
I was there to do my paperwork.
My employee was there working already.
She is the courageous one
who actually made the decision
to finally run away and get help.
So I just told there just
I wish her well.
You know,
hopefully she can get
a lot of help in her life.
And that's about it.
Gave her my number.
She has no I need time.
You need help.
Just please call police.
Definitely reach out.
That's incredibly kind of you.
And again, I'm sure she appreciates it.
Bobby, you've run
that gas station
for a few years, and oftentimes
gas stations,
for whatever reason, can be magnets
for strange things
and strange people often times.
Is this the weirdest thing
or the strangest thing
that you've ever encountered?
Strangest thing and weirdest thing.
Yes.
By far, we get regular incidents.
You know, about Waco,
or about stuff all the time.
But this is something
you can never imagine
would happen at a gas station.
But it's a weird thing.
But I am glad it happened.
I'm glad she's safe.